ردت شركه وتر على بيان الفنانه اليسا بفسخ
التعاقد معاهم على خلفيه الاشكالات او
الحقوق الملكيه الخاصه باغنيه انا وبس
اللي رجع قلناها زياد برجي ببيان مبارك
بداتم تمني انه لو كانت اليسا ومحاميها
احتكموا للقضاء فعلا وليس قولا بهذا الشان
وضحوا كمان انه اليسا صرحت على مسؤوليتها
المنفرده ملكيتها للحقوق الحصريه على
الاغنيه واللي سلمت فعلا اللي الشركه نسخه
منها ليتاحتها وفقا للعقد ما بينهم
[موسيقى]
واتباين فيما بعد ان نشا ما بين الفنانه
اليسا ومؤن في الاغنيه المذكوره فانتزمت
الشركه الحياه مؤكده خطيا لاليسا بانه لا
دخل لها بالنزاع القائم وانها راح تحدد
موقفها منه على ضوء الحكم القضائي النهائي
والمبره والذي يتم ابلاغها به رسميا
[موسيقى]
ايه اشتري هذه اللحظه لم تقوم بالرد على
هذا البيان في المقابل
[موسيقى]